this is a little more complicated so
let's let's walk through it slowly if a
hundred and eighty dollars again
highlight is invested for ten years the
amount of interest earned is 122 dollars
at fifty cents calculate the annual
simple interest rate as a percentage ok
so this type again we've got our
critical details there just a bit a
little bit and you can see again three
dollars right you'll frequently get
three doubles because if you come all
the way back to the simple interest
formula there are four numbers if you
want to find out what of them you need
to know all of the other three it's a
little bit like trying to solve a puzzle
you want it you've got one last piece
left if you go all the rest of them you
know where it's got to fit ok so in the
first case the first question that we
did just now you get given P R and M so
therefore you just substitute the mid
and that gives you the final answer
which is already over on the left hand
side by itself but look carefully this
next question that we're doing here it
says $108 10 years 123 dollars 50 what
to each of these numbers be one hundred
eighty dollars that's invested that's
the principle right that's the starting
about okay so i'll label that p 10 years
that's clear you got to be the number of
time periods when you have a look at
this last number it's not the interest
rate this is the about of interest
that's been bird so in fact this is I so
when I come back to that adds to my
question again just like I usually do
I'm going to begin by writing out the
formula so I equals P R M but here when
i go i had to do by substitution it's
going to look a little bit different
right it's going to have I on the left
hand side I actually know what that
number is it's a hundred at $23 add 50
sets right I also know what the
principal is it's a one hundred ninety
dollars but the interest rate are I
don't actually know it like that's
that's the question okay I'll calculate
the simple interest rate as a percentage
so I've kind of I can't put anything it
for our I just have to say it's our okay
I'll find that out in a minute lastly
I've got in i dunno what that is
it's 10 years now have a look at this
late of working I want you to think back
to able to do the algebra when you look
at something like this you're trying to
solve for R try to fight the value of
our all I need to do here is to
rearrange and bake are the subject I
want the equation that says R equals
okay and just before that like that's
where I'm going to finish you can see it
will help me if I do a little bit of
simplification here so you can see here
the right-hand side I've got these three
doubles multiplied together you can
multiply numbers in any order you like
so I've got the microdata at the tab I'm
going to multiply their that gives me
nine eight hundred dollars times are
then I've got this interests about the
actual dollars over here on the left
side so you can see here if I want our
by itself all I need to do is to divide
both sides by what does it nine hundred
dollars doing the same thing to both
sides because it's an equation or snails
stays balanced out on the right hand
side you can see kids or kids so I'll be
left with r by itself that's what i want
so I'll go say R equals and to get the
other side I just need to evaluate this
fracture that I see on the left so let's
do that two three okay now this is what
my calculator is telling me and this is
my occasion to explain why in my
previous example I said even though we'd
have a percentage button on our
calculator I don't really want to write
my percentage as a percentage I want to
write it as a decimal have a look at
what else I has been given to us this
this number here this is a decimal and
there's no sort of twisting attorney you
could make your calculator do to hand it
back to you automatically a percentage
you have to recognize this and be able
to work out well what is that as a
percentage it's a decimal right now how
am I going to work with it so here is my
advice this is point zero six five i'm
going to multiply it by something that
keeps the note that the save but adds
the percentage side of the sign okay so
here's what i'm going to multiply by you
might have seen this before in previous
classes i'm going to multiply by one hi
druid % ok like if you have another I
think of a number and if you have a
hundred percent of that no bar the
number hasn't changed has it like x a
Hydra press it doesn't actually change
the value so this guy over here has it
mucked around with my bill by it's still
gonna be the same theory but now I have
a percent cited in my actual expression
so I could say well now we'll do the 100
times that number 100 times and if
you're really good with this you'll do
you just have to move that decimal place
twice and say that's going to become 6.5
at opposite side is he off on the air
just like we wanted to so you can see
the way that I've worked this out I've
looked carefully at the beginning and
I've said well what actually information
do I have don't just go substituting in
blindly think before you write and say
okay I know that this is the formula but
where am I going to put the values in
the question these guys we're in the
formula are they going to go that's the
key skill be assessed not memorizing
your formula okay which is why it's
given to you on your formula sheet right
so these are the simple interest
calculations that you're expected to see